the trailer for director near to casters
Candyman a spiritual sequel to the 1992
horror classic of the same name has
finally been released online and it
promises plenty of cerebral thrills of
the kind that we've come to associate
with producer and co-writer Jordan Peele
not to mention an inspired take on a
story that sent chills down the spines
of horror fans three decades ago these
are just a few things that may have
slipped by you in that excellent new
trailer
Yaya Abdul Mateen ii portrays anthony
mccoy he moves into the neighborhood
near chicago's cabrini-green housing
projects the area which was once
terrorized by Daniel Robitaille that's
the titular hook wielding spectres real
name by the way these days though it
looks a little different the area has
become near completely gentrified with
most of the buildings comprising the out
housing projects having been demolished
in their place of ritzy high-rises
houses shops and art museums the latter
of which may be what drew McCoy to the
area McCoy you see is an artist just
like Robitaille himself apparently he's
a pretty talented one as a trailer
implies that it doesn't take him long to
score an exhibit in his new neighborhood
it looks like Candyman will see McCoy
becoming just a wee bit obsessed with
robotized legend which is a focus of the
exhibit hell it's even includes an
arrangement of mirrors the mirror
invites you to summon him a spot reveals
that McCoy begins to identify with
Roberto just a bit too closely and their
shared profession raises a question of
how else they might be connected is
mccoy a descendant of Candyman or even
the reincarnation of the doomed artist
in the original film it was heavily
implied that Helen may have been
Caroline Sullivan robotized lover
reincarnated it's not clear what the
connection is but it seems certain
other-- is one what's a troubled corner
of Chicago but the area that was home to
the Cabrini Green housing projects has
changed pretty drastically over the
years the fact of Cabrini greens
gentrification is a fascinating aspect
of this new candyman's plots and one
which producer and co-writer Jordan
Peele is sure to mind for a truckload of
thematic resonance interestingly though
the trailer makes it plain now while the
area has undergone quite the
revitalization its past isn't completely
buried fragments of it remain such as
the old boarded-up buildings where McCoy
first encounters William Burke played by
Colman Domingo
who appears to be a longtime resident
the idea here seems to be that a
troubled violent past could never truly
be buried
not even by pricey condos and upscale
restaurants hey the truth hurts
literally don't say to the other spots
end is a really starts to pick up steam
with the lightning quick edits and
disturbing imagery a voice creeps in on
the soundtrack and if you're a fan of
the original movie you recognized it
immediately yup it's the man himself
that's the voice of Tony Todd who's
restrained yet intense performance made
Candyman such a frightening presence in
the 1992 flick for a good chunk of the
time the film was in production it was
thought that AB Dorma team would be
replacing tardis Candyman obviously this
isn't the case but the Custer isn't
particularly keen to let us know what
the case is or exactly how large a part
Todd will have in the new film in March
2019 the director told Collider it's
been slightly misreported I can't say
what's happening in the film because he
wanted to be a surprise but Abdul Mateen
is not replacing Tony Todd that's been
reported and I was just like I don't
know what to say about this this is not
right since we never see candy man's
face in the trailer
only his bloody hook we can't say with
certainty that Todd will reprise his
role but he is definitely involved and
that can only be a good thing we'll see
just what peeled to Custer and company
have cooked up for us when Candyman hits
a big screen on June 12 2020 check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]